the virus spread is slowing in the north
but focus is turning to growing tension
in the south
police now patrol supermarkets after the
threat of raids and theft people short
of money food but not anger and that
anger has become inflamed after claims
the woman near Naples was one of those
who fled the north when the lockdown
came in bringing kovat 19 with the news
came on social media from the mayor of a
town near Naples claiming they'd only
discovered this woman had coated 19
after being in the area for 20 days the
mayor's announcement sparked a protest
outside the young woman's home this
image emerging online she hit back in an
emotional video posted on social media
it's unappealing
so because of this we as tensions build
in the south there's no respite yet for
the country's health care 61 doctors
have now died from kovat 19 along with
eleven and a half thousand citizens just
five and a half weeks scientists and the
government have met separately to
discuss what happens next the prime
minister in office today taking video
conference calls on the crisis
epidemiologists remain concerned a virus
is continuing to grow at a faster rate
in areas of the south than it is in the
rest of the country the government here
though is also all too aware of the need
to relieve the social and economic
tensions of
this lockdown it's not yet clear if or
how they'll manage to do both it'll be a
careful balancing act the head of
Italy's Emergency Response says the
virus may now be at its peak but
lockdown will only be lifted one step at
a time that we are really confident and
we really hope that we go to the highest
point point and now we've started
getting down and what does that mean for
people with lockdown when will that be
lifted it means that they can see light
they can see that they can be the
lockdown can be open and probably every
will be the amount that with this will
happen so when will life return to some
sense of normality for people if we can
call it that
hopefully by May May July can be Meijin
can be a good period we really hope that
we really hope for that the end light
for many still feels a long way off the
government has now made four hundred
million euros available for people who
can't buy food here in Naples this
basket asks people to add something if
they can and take if they can't a kind
gesture in an area bubbling with stress
and concern sunny Lockwood Sky newsroom